Pok saddam is a famous south korean
actress who made international waves in
2019 when she starred as ki-jong AKA
Jessica in parasite in this video we
dive into Saddam's private life
revealing everything from how she
struggled to become an actress and her
views on plastic surgery to who she is
dating and how she spends her free time
keep watching to find out which American
celebrity so Dom was most excited to
meet at the 2019 governors awards Park
so Dom was born in South Korea on
September 8 1991 but the thought of
becoming an actress wouldn't cross her
mind until she entered her freshman year
in high school during an interview with
drama beans so Dom revealed that she
began to consider acting after watching
the musical Grease and noticing how
happy his cast members looked the star
revealed that she never had a dream
before realizing that acting was the
path for her but coming to terms with
this wasn't always easy since so Dom's
parents were feverishly against their
firstborn pursuing an acting career but
this didn't faze the go-getter who
believes that a life without acting was
a life with no meaning despite her
parents being vocal about wanting her to
live an ordinary life so Dom consulted
her two younger siblings on the matter
and they encouraged her to follow her
dreams when asked about her siblings so
Dom reveals that she has a younger
sister who is her biggest supporter and
a brother who is the youngest out of the
three the actors told drama beans that
her parents continued to have children
until they got the boy they wanted high
school Park so Dom enrolled in the
Korean National University of Arts and
would graduate with dozens of
independent movies already under her
belt 15 to be exact instead of waiting
to graduate from university before
auditioning for roles so Dom chose to
actively pursue acting throughout her
studies however movie and TV show roles
didn't come easy to the aspiring actress
who was constantly rejected by casting
agents and directors so Dom opened up
about the many struggles she faced
during the mid DC events in 2016 he or
she revealed that she odd
for a total of 17 different roles in one
single month only to be rejected each
and every time but instead of admitting
defeat so Dom chose to pursue
independent films and came out on top
this proved to be a wise decision as
starring and independent films gave her
the recognition she needed and after
just two short years she was able to set
her sights on bigger projects so Dom
aspires to be like South Korean actress
Kim Chi su
who is known for her versatile acting
skills since graduating from the Korean
National University of Arts Park so Dom
has become a highly requested actress
and the same can be said about her
classmates Kim go hoon and Lee Yoo young
however when asked if she harbored any
rivalry towards them so Dom revealed
that while they can be seen as her
competitors she does not see them as
rivals during her interview with the
drama beans so Dom said that she is
happy to support her classmates since
there aren't many South Korean actresses
in their 20s and she's glad that the
industry is shifting before Saddam
gained international fame with parasites
she experienced more than a few setbacks
like that time her TV show got cancelled
after just 14 episodes the actor starred
as Jean sung on the South Korean TV
series beautiful mind in 2016 and so Dom
confessed that there were a lot of tears
while filming the last episode of the
series however she was told that her
career wouldn't suffer from the
cancellation which proved to be true
because the same year so Dom would start
filming for the TV show Cinderella and
the four nights and years later in 2018
so Dom's world would get turned upside
down when she landed the role of a
lifetime takeoff misery chakra to
converge a universe in Toronto
after starring in the 2015 film the
priests park sodam
experienced when actors would call a
slump at the time she wasn't signed to
an agency and had to fight tooth and
nail for her roles but that all changed
when Saddam was approached for the role
of the poser tutor Jessica from parasite
so Dom revealed to Soompi that she was
startled when director bong joho
contacted her on the phone
inviting her to audition for a role in
his upcoming movie at first she thought
he had called the wrong person but
things began to feel very real when so
Dom met director bong face-to-face after
accepting the role she didn't hear from
the director for a total of two months
which made her feel uneasy she had
feared that he had changed his mind but
in the end everything worked out as
planned
connecting with her character was an
easy thing to do for the experienced
actress so Dom used her personal life
experiences to bond with ki-jong who
despite being the second born acted like
an older sister to her on-screen brother
so Dom revealed that taking care of her
younger siblings is something she has
done since she was a kid so she used her
real life experience to fuel her
character's personality and sharp
attitude keep watching to find out who
so DOM is rumored to be dating is every
actors dream to be recognized as an
a-list actor all over the world but for
park so Dom this dream has become a
reality she never once expected that
director bonks film would garner
international acclaim but before so Dom
knew it she and her fellow cast members
were taking over the world one award
ceremony at a time during an interview
with Wonderland magazine so Dom said
that she is so grateful for having been
chosen to portray ki-jung she explained
that 2019 and 2020 had been jam-packed
and unreal in more ways than one
not only has she been able to work with
extremely talented people but she has
been able to witness firsthand how the
film has impacted different nations so
Dom was delighted to see that parasite
hit home for both North American and
South Korean viewers she commented on
how some Western audiences for brought
to tears while watching the film
although Park Saddam is thrilled to be
making waves in Western cinema she knows
that there is still a long way to go but
it's
happy to be contributing parasite has
brought home dozens of awards and it is
the first South Korean film to win an
Oscar however many would agree that the
cast did not receive the recognition
they deserve
on Yamaha Canton I opinion whoever
doesn't pero touches Haile Park so Dom
is 28 years old and currently single
much to everyone's surprise the star has
managed to keep her dating history under
wraps which isn't an easy thing to do
while living in the limelight for now so
Dom seems to be focusing on her acting
career instead of her dating life if she
is dating someone she is making it a
point to keep it on the down-low there
are no hints of a romantic relationship
on the stars Instagram page but most
surprisingly so Dom has managed to evade
every single question that was designed
to unravel her love life while most
actresses her age gush about their
perfect man to media so Dom has refrains
from making a single comments curiously
enough dating celebs reports that park
sodam
has had at least one relationship in her
life however her ex partner's name has
not surfaced so Dom has talked about how
difficult it is to juggle her
professional and social life since
making it as an actress whatever spare
time she has she chooses to spend it
with friends and family luckily many of
her close friends are actors as well so
they understand what it's like to have a
hectic schedule keep watching to find
out which South Korean star is best
friends with so Dom tomone you don't to
be someone new you know English it might
come as a surprise to find out that
South Korea has the highest number of
cosmetic procedures per capita in the
world according to a survey conducted by
Gallup Korea in 2015 up to 14 percent of
teenage women have undergone plastic
surgery in South Korea and this number
jumps to 30% when regarding adult women
one of the most common procedures
amongst South Korean celebrities is
double eyelid surgery and believe it or
not but park sodam has been encouraged
to receive the surgery on multiple
occasions however the actress is adamant
about not wanting to get any plastic
surgery done according to glamour path
so Dom is not 100% satisfied with her
looks still the thought of receiving
plastic surgery has never crossed her
mind she is proud to have a face that no
one can duplicate through sir
and she is glad to have made it as an
actress without needing to alter her
features so Dom believes that actors can
benefit from having their unique charms
park so Dom isn't someone who has an
open schedule however when an opening
does come up she makes sure to spend it
with her friends and family during an
interview with drama beans so Dom
revealed that it's hard to get together
with her friends due to scheduling
conflicts many of her close friends are
in the acting world too which makes
getting together even more challenging
because of this so Dom often meets up
with her high school friends or anyone
who lives nearby as she does not enjoy
venturing too far away from home so Dom
would consider her little sister as one
of her best friends and the older she
gets the closer they become so Dom is
also good friends with actress che so
Binh who was all set to co-star on the
TV drama half of half so Dom is a
thoughtful friend who had encouraging
banners made for so been to pump her up
while on the set of the show
Shannon loose petal during an interview
with W Magazine so Dom talks about
attending numerous awards ceremonies in
North America and she revealed that she
was most excited to meet Charlize Theron
at the governors awards turns out even
someone as famous as so Dom can get
starstruck so Dom said that Charlize was
behind her in the queue for pictures and
that she was so nervous about meeting
her that she doesn't remember being
photographed when asked about her
favorite Charlize Theron movie so Dom
immediately said Mad Max she revealed
that she watched that movie as she was
preparing to shave her own head for a
role and that Charlize unknowingly
helped her commit to the haircut the
sky's the limit for the South Korean
actress whose newest film Fukuoka
recently premiered at the Berlin
International Film Festival in February
of 2020 so Dom who also happens to be a
singer is also interested in pursuing
musical theater so keep an eye out for
the rising star what did you think of
the movie parasite tell us in the
comments section and even up on y'all
and that's a wrap thanks for watching
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up and be sure to subscribe
to the things for more great content see
you later